actuellement la france et où une
nouvelle tendance donc celle des
mariages mixtes comment ça se passe vous
avez voulu lever le viage moyens oui
enfin ça surtout posé la question volée
une passe terrifiés non c'est autre non
je suis toujours
je me suis surtout posé la question pour
les gens de notre génération qu'est ce
que ça signifie aujourd'hui un mariage
dit mixte parce qu'avant mariages mixtes
était un étranger ou une étrangère avec
un français ou une française pour notre
génération ce sont deux français avec
une culture différente avec le mariage
pour tous aujourd'hui un mariage mixte
ça peut être aussi un homme avec une
femme dont je me suis posé la question
puis après j'ai su que vous vous étiez
un mariage mixte cet été mais j'étais au
mariage de ma fille dont qui a épousé un
anglais dont le père est juif derrick sm
caen mais son problème c'est la deuxième
qui se marie avec un je dis donc ça va
et quand ça veut pas sourire est là et
donc sa mère la mère de ce garçon est
non seulement d'origine indienne mais en
plus rares et krishna
enfants mariages indiens
next ou pas on peut lui faire mal je
mixe oui bien sûr parce que ma fille est
catholique au départ j'avais senti le
choc des cultures ou pas moi j'adore
giorgio wrightson j'adore arrêté isna
j'étais ravi devant c'est un bien chez
moi et comme j'ai rien contre les juifs
tout va bien moi j'ai voulu inquiéter un
peu plus sur ce sur ce qu'on appelle
mariages dits mixtes donc je suis allé
rencontrer un couple dit mixte de la
première génération
lui s'appelle nordine il arrivé en
france à l'âge de 17 ans il était
plongeurs elle elle s'appelle virginie
c'est sa femme et aujourd'hui ça fait 17
ans qu'ils sont ensemble et les devenu
même le chef du restaurant et on regarde
encore manier tous
[Musique]
ça ne fait pas de revenir ici 17 ans
plus tard
[Musique]
c'était hier à se marier une autre fois
allégé avec les arbres mari et femme
voulait embrasser la mariée
[Musique]
j'ai de mon enfant
moi j'ai recopié un poème de baudelaire
way et judas et là je lui dis tu veux
que je te lise alors il commence à lire
je lui lis
on se lève on s'embrasse la a et c'est
comme ça qu'on se passe oui
mais alors d'origine qu'est ce qu'on
mange voilà la viande de salers qui ont
été chercher tout à l'heure ouais
voisins les girolles conesa et pichet
tout à l'heure ouais et un foie gras au
curcuma maison maison tout est maison
est relevé à la raffinerie sauvage très
bien
moi je grandis avec les règles c'est mon
jus ce que tu veux et habille toi comme
ton voisin donc à l'extérieur on est
tous paille et chez soi qu'on est comme
neo si on arrête ils ont envie de
transmettre à mes enfants et mon père
m'a dit ça quand j'étais petit dessus
les règles chez toi tu es chez toi à
l'extérieur tout le monde
d'ailleurs fait des malheurs de la
finale est licite et avec un accent
tunisien donc c'est impossible
magnifique voilà on est d'accord ils
sont incroyables déjà ils ont usé
précieux ce monsieur est comme moi
contre les voiles contre les djellabas
dans les rues et esbly à la française il
y parle exactement s'habille comme un
jeu il est très bien à ma meuf à rome
fais comme les romains voilà donc je me
suis pas arrêté là dans mon enquête
parce que vous savez bien dans dans les
moeurs ont changé notre nouvelle
génération nés deux français deux
cultures différentes donc j'ai cherché
un couple en dehors du mien qui était un
peu dans cette même configuration et
sans vouloir faire de l'entretoit je
suis allé rencontrer abcès toucy et
vincent cerutti qu'ils sont un couple
médiatique et gg je les ai rencontrés
parce qu'ils ont vraiment quelque chose
à dire sur le sujet est aussi surtout
j'ai été touché parce que c'était la
première fois qu'il se confier sur leur
couple et sur les difficultés qu'ils ont
pu déjà rencontré c'est un scoop
absolument mamier douceur alors ça tout
ce que tu es très populaires sur les
réseaux sociaux tu reçois de nombreux
messages de soutien et d'amour mais
aussi des fois tu reçois des messages
surprenant de messages de haine alors je
te demande et vincent de le lire et
j'aimerais qu'on le commente ensemble
d'accords salue la noire qui se prend
pour une blanche qui renie ses origines
et sa religion tab et ses tons froids
que pour la réussite espèce de vendu tu
dégoûte ton mec le blanc chrétien il
n'est pas musulman toi tu t'en fous de
toute façon tu es pas musulmane tueur ni
la religion tes origines
pour la gloire applause c'est lui un qui
m'aidait applause parti de rien il
reprend le titre de ton libre et écarter
ses jambes pour la réussite on est
obligé de continuer cette école de
l'irsa de savoir qu'on envoie ça c'est
terrible c'est honteux ça verbalement
dans la rue je peux m'énerver et
demander de l'aide de l'aide à qui de
droit oui en effet je pense à des poids
de plein-vent courant des choses comme
ça après sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est difficile qu'est ce que tu veux
faire bah qu'est ce que tu veux faire je
pense qu'à un moment il faut quand même
un minimum dénoncer ça presque un
message comme ça ok moi j'en reçois
quand même beaucoup j'en ai reçu
énormément pendant les émissions où
j'étais très
visible où on appelait à mon violent où
on appelait à des choses qui qui qui est
touché à ma famille est la raison je
crois que c'est quoi cette différence au
vide parce que vous êtes différent non
c'est quoi la raison parce que il ya de
la jalousie parce qu'effectivement on
incarne quelque chose que certains ne
veulent pas voir dans la société
française sagem et plus tard une
différence qui normalement ne se
mélangent pas
c'est très touchant on lit ce message il
est nauséabond et absatou on reçoit
énormément on t'a déjà dit je vais te
péter les dents comme dans american
history and american stories donc
finalement fait cette guerre civile dont
vous parlez en on va la voir des deux
côtés
vilon général s'étaient tous côtés oui
on essaye d'obtenir le juste milieu oui
absolument inouïe elles sont extrêmement
triste on sait louis philippe pons et
puis voilà oui mais est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu si les deux extrêmes se
nourrissent de ce genre de discours que
vous n'avez
ce n'est pas moi qui nourrit quoi que ce
soit c'est une réalité malheureusement
la guerre civile elle viendra et elle
voit pas mais a souhaité vous la
souhaite un garçonnet savez je ne
souhaite jamais les gardes civils parce
que c'est la pire guerre qui puisse
arriver est un jour les gens se diront
qui est ce que c'est la guerre civile ou
est ce que c'est la soumission à l'islam
ça sera le sujet on y est déjà dans
beaucoup de quartiers on y est déjà
regardez qui l'insultent qu'il met sur
l'art il lui dit qu'il lui dit qu'elle
ne qu'elle ne connaît pas sa religion
n'est pas moi mais vous ne savez pas ce
qu'est ce que vous savez ce qu'on dit
mais vous ne savez pas qui est derrière
vous fait peur mais sauve arcade reçu
oui mais c'est surtout que je vais vous
dire que quand des personnes françaises
comme vous comme moi disent ah ben c'est
tout tu es
ça a été violent le beau et la bête
vincent comment peux-tu te mettre avec
un singe des choses de doter de cette
violence-là bien je considère que
la france en tout cas dans laquelle nous
avons grandi a aussi beaucoup de là
aussi beaucoup de messages d'amour mais
aussi du racisme qui est qui qui se
nourrit de toutes les équipes parce que
j'ai une petite question je le savoir
monsieur zemmour je pense que vous avez
des filles si demain votre fille sort
avec un arabe ou un noir et elle se
retrouve à la place de monsieur cerruti
la lire ce genre de message j'aimerais
savoir un peu vous vous allez je vais
vous répéter façon près je voulais
répondre c'est votre reportage est très
intéressant mais il donne raison vous
savez je vais vous citer une phrase de
benjamin constant et vous allez complet
benjamin constant disait tout et morale
chez les individus tout et physiques
dans les masses c'est à dire quel
individu est libre parce qu'il n'a de
rapport qu'avec un autre individu dès
qu'il rentre dans une masse il n'est
plus libre vous nous parlez de mariages
mixtes et vous nous dites c'est
magnifique c'est beau c'est l'amour
c'est pas en train de dire que c'est ici
mais c'est très bien c'est l'amour vous
avez raison c'est très beau maintenant
aujourd'hui la réalité des mariages
mixtes où 80 % à 90 % d'énergie mais
qu'est ce que c'est c'est des jeunes
d'ici issus de l'immigration arabo
musulmane pour la plupart qui vont
chercher des jeunes filles au bled les
ramènent regarder les chiffres c'est pas
moi c'est lui mais tous les végétaux
séchés voulez mais je voulais chanter
même libération m'a donné raison l'étagé
déjà techniques sont interdites en
france mais c'est pas le pied que c'est
le nationalisme bancaire comment vous
arrivez dans tosca mariam national et
noir et un mariage ma nation de hockey
marianne vous apprenez aujourd'hui c'est
les chiffres de l'an et anouar cette
année donc même libération m'a donné
raison vous n'aimez pas avoir tort parce
que les stages et parcours j'ai raison
interdite en france comment vous
aujourd'hui chiffré les personnes issues
d'un couple milanesi on a dit que vous
étiez un peu ce qu'on dit l'invs ou la
nationalité dans un final sorti des
chiffres alors on passe par les factuel
mais c'est très simple il ya à peu près
si je me souviens bien dans les 80000
mariages mixtes et la plupart sont ce
que je viens de dire parce que ça c'est
des cas exceptionnels ce sont non mais
la majorité c'est sûr je vous dis si je
fais ça alimente et ça alimente
l'immigration régulière ce ne sont pas
des cas exceptionnels si la table vous
avez franz olivier giesbert qui est un
couple mixte hapsatou aussi moi aussi
raquel aussi si je peux me permettre
c'est pas la définition officielle du
couple mixte n'a misé sur le couple
mixte tel qu'il est défini par les
statistiques démographiques
c'est en effet en fonction de ce que
j'aimerais c'est donc cadeau n'est pas
reconnu
le mélange
s'il vous plaît et ce que je veux faire
remarquer simplement que je trouve
personnellement qu'on exagère beaucoup
le sujet que ça me passionne pas que je
me fous si c'est un couple mixte ou pas
un couple mixte et que je ne regarde pas
si mais qu'à faire vraiment là je m'en
fous non mais c'est très sincèrement en
ce qui me concerne ça n'est pas une
question qui m'obsède finalement ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui
kinder par exemple ils vont ajouter un
emoji couples mixtes et ce qui est
rassurant pour la france c'est qu'ils
ont fait une enquête et 81 % des
utilisateurs teaser en france ont déjà
eu rendez vous avec quelqu'un qui ont
une culture différente alors qu aux
états-unis seulement 70% donc finalement
en france on aime les différences on
aime le vivre ensemble et on aime le
vivre ensemble
oui
ces corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus